Hello, everyone.
This is Isaac
Kurtzer, the Department
of Biomedical
Science, Old
Westbury campus.
And here we have our
second lecture on
cranial nerve nuclei,
those related to
cranial nerves 5, as
well as 7 through 12.
A wide number of
objectives today because
we're going to be
covering a wide number of
cranial nerves and
cranial nerve nuclei. it's
going to be all of them
aside from old-fashioned
vision and eye movements
so you're going
to need to understand
the particular
information that's going
to be relayed by all those
remaining um nerves
you're going to understand
the relationship
between the cranial
nerve nuclei and those
nerves and understand
the general organization
of those nuclei within
the brainstem and
finally you need to
understand how particular
injuries will relate
to dysfunction along
these pathways where it's
identifiable to nerves
a nuclei and that's
a very complex pattern
because of this non
because of the
complexity between nerves
to nuclei that many
a nerve can carry
information related
to several nuclei and
nuclei can be
transmitting information
along different nerve
tracks so that's
really where the complexity
comes in and we're
going to really try
to tie it all together
in this lecture here
we have a complete
listing of all the
cranial nerve nuclei
that have a motor
function be it somatic be
it brachial be it
visceral we have the
associated nerve or nerves
linked to that nuclei
listed as well and
lastly the effector
systems involved so
abducens nucleus is
going to only be related
to a single nerve
and it's going to impact
eye movement control
actually just of a
single muscle directly
the lateral ******
to enable abduction
of the eye so we went
over the um three
nerves for the eye that
was really simple but
it's going to be
getting increasingly
complex as we go throughout
this list it starts
out pretty simple
here and for the next
slide it's going to
be more complex with
the cranial nerve
nucleic sensory function
It is the complete
list of cranial nerve
nuclei that have a
sensory function.
All of these nuclei
will be second order
neurons that will be
receiving afferent
information from the
periphery relayed by
the given nerves that
you see listed to
the side. It might
be visceral sensory
afferents, mass sensory
afferents, special
sensory afferents,
but they're all going
to be targeting
these nuclei. They're
listed, and they'll
have a role in sensory
function that will
be indicated on the
right. Take your time
going through this
slide and the previous
slide. Hit pause.
Really kind of make
notes, however it is, to
get yourself prepped
for the material that
follows. Because if you
were able to do this,
you'd already have
the lecture here. It
says, I need to now walk
through each of these
connections in detail
because it is difficult.
So try to do some
prep work beforehand.
So there's a key at
the bottom of a number
of figures that's
going to have the same
coloring as what we
saw for the functions
before. So motor is
always something kind of
like in the yellow,
orange, red scheme. and
then we have green
blue and purple for the
sensory functions just
as help keep that in
your mind I won't be
writing brachial motor
on every slide I'll be
having I'll be having
something described
with a given color so
that's what I'm
referring to this slide
shows the same information
that we had in the
previous two but now
with the placement of
these cranial nerve
nuclei within the brain
stem so midbrain pons
medulla the most rostral
of all the nuclei
would be the editing
westfall the most caudal
would be the trigeminal
spinal insofar as
a very long nucleus
and the most caudal
portion is in fact found
within the cervical
spinal cord. So again,
take your time going
through all of this
information before we
go to the next slide.
And lastly, we have
all the information
put together in a chart
form where the nerves
are going to be
defining the rows and
the function are going
to be defining the
columns and people can
get heart palpitations
at this point but
they shouldn't
because there's only
some only so much that
is very difficult to
understand much of it
is very easy to understand
so the hypoglossal
nucleus is very
straightforward because
it's one nucleus
associated with one
nerve that has a
very straightforward
function to control the
tongue And the cranial
nerve 8 is going to
be related to the
vestibular nucleus,
the cochlear nucleus,
and it's called
vestibular cochlear nerve.
So that's very
straightforward.
cranial nerve five this
is pretty much easy
enough because uh
on the right we have
that it's going to be
uh these three nuclei
the trigeminal
mesosophallic pontine and
uh spinal all have
to do with um touch
and proprioception uh
for the face or pain
and temperature for
the face so it's all
about sensory information
about the face
and the trigeminal
motor is for the jaw so
that's pretty yoked
together now remember
the cranial nerve
nuclear always sensory
or always motor it
can't be both whereas
the cranial nerves
can be mixed
they'll be conveying
afferents that are
conveying afferents
and efferents sensory
information and
motor information
and overall 12 is
easy eight is easy
five is easy seven is
tough er but there's
a helpful vignette
that i'm going
to give you nine is
a bit more complex
i got a helpful name
for you and then
10 is is admittedly
quite tough but there
is a pattern within
here so we start with
cranial nerve five, which
are going to be yoked
to motor nuclei and
sensory nuclei. So
this image shows the
trigeminal nucleus. It
doesn't give any further
information about a
subdivision of that
trigeminal nucleus. And
the parentheses five
means the information
about this motor
nucleus will be relayed
these via five on the
right we have again
trigeminal nuclei not
given with any further
definitions other than
saying sensory and the
aspirants to those
nuclei are going to be
traveling along the
trigeminal nerve the um
cranial nerve uh seven
nine and ten so we'll
be discussing seven
nine and ten later
we're going to be
focusing on cranial nerve
five and then referring
to the nuclei that
it's going to be involved
in which are going
to be on the motor side
and the sensory side
because As I can see,
five on both sides.
So there are three
different divisions
of the trigeminal
nerve, hence tri.
We have one, two, and
three, which will be
called ophthalmic
maxillary mandibular. The
first two, we're laying
information that is
somatosensation, so
these are all afferents.
And the mandibular is
going to be a mixed
nerve. Turning to the
nuclei, we have the
trigeminal pontine
nucleus, which is going to
be processing information
from those three
nerve divisions solely
related to touch and
proprioception. This is
going to be analogous
to the cuneate and
gracile nuclei of the
dorsal column. They
are second order nuclei
processing touch and
proprioception for the
body. This would be for
the face. And so the
trigeminal spinal nucleus
would be processing
afferent information
about pain and
temperature. So this
would be analogous to the
nucleus procreus in the
spinal cord that will
then be forming the
spinal thalamic tract.
I should also note that
they're going to be
processing information,
these nuclei are
going to be processing
information, not just
from the face, but
also the eye. And it's
going to be because you
can feel pressure on
the eye, right? It can
hurt if you scratch
your eye, right? Well,
that information is
going to be relayed
through the trigeminal
nerve to those respective
nuclei. And there's
going to be information
targeting these
nuclei coming from other
cranial nerves. And
that would be relaying
touch information,
let's just say, for the
tongue and upper throat
vis-a-vis cranial
nerve 9. And we'll go
over that soon enough.
But I'm trying to
reemphasize that these
nuclei are going to be
processing information
from several nerves.
the face is the most
prominent of those,
and that's going to
be for this nerve.
Now, turning to
trigeminal mesosemphalic
nucleus and the motor
nucleus right below
it, I link those
together because this is
going to be supporting
a jaw-**** reflex.
So the trigeminal
motor nucleus is
going to have the
cell bodies to drive
various muscles of
mastication like
masseter like
temporalis and that
would be through
that mixed nerve v3
also the jaw
proprioception is relayed
um uh um involves
this mesosimphallic
nucleus and
interestingly enough this
quote nucleus it's a
nucleus because it's
within it's a cell
body within the
parenchyma of the
brain it's inside the
brain stem at a mid
-brain level but the
cell body actually
is for a first order
afferent okay so that's
not a second order
afference it's as if
you took a dorsal root
ganglia and just shoved
it into the spinal
cord so this is a very
unique situation um i
can't think of any
other examples of it but
it should be noted
that that That nucleus
for proprioception for
the jaw is going to
be then sending an axon
and a synapse to the
trigeminal motor nucleus,
and that together
will allow a stretch
reflex for the jaw.
This is a transverse
section through the
pons, which is going
to provide a view of
the trigeminal pontine
nucleus that is involved
in face mass
sensation. So touch and
proprioception for the
face is a very large
nucleus. They also
call it the principal
trigeminal nucleus.
That's the same thing
as the trigeminal
pontine nuclei we're not
going to show sections
throughout the
brainstem because
remember it goes from mid
midbrain all the way to
the most caudal portion
of the medulla for
the spinal trigeminal
nucleus this slide
does a good job showing
you the various fields
or the portions of
the trigeminal nerve
the territory that
they'll innervate for
ophthalmic maxillary
and mandibular we have
nuclei there shown
and they're going to
be boxed according to
whether they're going
to be sensory or motor
i want to also point
out that the back
of the head is going
to have its cutaneous
information handled by
a a spinal nerve C2.
The pontine trigeminal
nucleus is located
within the pons. It
will be receiving touch
and proprioceptive
information about the
ipsilateral face. It's
a second-order neuron.
The first-order neurons
for it have their
cell bodies within the
trigeminal ganglia.
The spinal trigeminal
nucleus runs from the
lowermost pons to
upper spinal cord, so
the third cervical
segment of the spinal
cord, and this very
long column of nuclei is
going to be processing
information from the
ipsilateral face
regarding pain and
temperature. So those
first-order afferents also
have their cell body
within the trigeminal
ganglion. Now let's
just say that we had a
section through the
upper medulla like so.
This would not
interfere with the
transmission of
information about touch and
proprioception because
those first order
afferents will be
targeting the unaffected
pontine trigeminal
nucleus which would
then have its its
axons the axons of the
second order neuron
would decussate and
to ascend to the
thalamus. In contrast,
this section would
disrupt the flow of
information from the
first order afferents to
the second order
afferents for pain and
temperature. So
there cannot be pain
and temperature
information transmitted
to the second
order afferents, hence
they cannot relay it
to the thalamus. So
putting that together,
one would have a loss
of temperature and
pain for one side of
the face, but intact
touch and proprioception.
The last thing I
want to point out here
is the mesoemphalic
trigeminal nucleus and
the motor nucleus. So
these mesoemphalic,
these are first order
afferents. That's where
their cell bodies are,
as opposed to the
trigeminal ganglion
targeting the pontine
and the spinal divisions.
These first order
afferents of the
mesosophallic nucleus will
lay jaw proprioception
and they will have
a direct link to the
trigeminal motor
nucleus, which is located
here, sending its inference
out to control the
jaw on the ipsilateral
side for clinical
conditions that would
involve cranial nerve
five bands associated
nuclei we could have
an impact to the face
that could selectively
damage one of the
three divisions of the
trigeminal nerve so
just like knock out the
ophthalmic branch
for example there's
trigeminal neurologia
so this is thought to be
caused by demyelination
of the nerve
regardless it refers to
this recurrent intense
pain that would involve
the eyes the lips
the face and recurrent
meaning hundreds of
times a day. It's
not like oh well once
every couple hours I
have some pain. It just
goes on and on and on
and it's so disruptive
that they call it
the suicide disease.
And lastly among our
examples we have the
loss of the corneal reflex.
So this would require
afferent information
traveling through
this cranial nerve. You
can test this by just
you know having a light
touch of the eyelids
with a q-tip and if
somebody is not expressing
that then you know
right off that there
is going to be a problem
it could be tracked
down to the afferent
limb of v1 turn now
cranial nerve 7 the
facial nerve and the motor
nuclei associated with
it would be the facial
motor nucleus and
superior salivary nucleus
the sensory nuclei
will be divisions of
the trigeminal sensory
trigeminal nuclei if
you have any question
you just look do I see
a seven in here yes I
do do I see a seven in
here yes I do and
that's why we're talking
about it the cranial
nerve nuclei that are
yoked to this nerve
include the facial motion
nucleus which is going
to be controlling all
the facial expression
muscles on the
ipsilateral face as
well as some upper neck
musculature as well as
little old stapedius which
is the smallest striated
muscle in the body
we have the superior
salivatory nucleus, which
is ultimately going
to be controlling the
lacrimal gland vis-a-vis
a peripheral ganglion,
as well as the glands
for saliva within
the mouth itself,
submandibular and sublingual.
We have the gustatory
nucleus, which is
going to be very important
for relaying taste
for the front two
-thirds of the tongue,
and the trigeminal
nucleus that's going to be
relaying information
about skin on
the external ear.
Now, this is quite a
bit of material.
How do you put all
this together? And
I have this cheeky
little vignette
that's partially
inspired by my time
in Queens, New York.
And so humor me here.
Enjoying a Greek
olive, not chewing,
just tasting and smiling
and drooling a bit.
And the tears well up.
It's just so tasty.
And then my wife drags
me out of the store
by the ear. Okay, so
this has all of the
components there. It's
not jaw chewing. It's
not the mastication
muscles. It's just tasting
and smiling. And so
we have the upper and
lower half of the face
muscles for that and
drooling a bit. So
that's yolk to salivatory
nucleus and tears once
again. And lastly,
because I was distractible,
my wife pulls me
out of the store by my
ear so that's the uh
taste excuse me the uh
the uh somatosensory
uh information uh
that's going to be going
to the trigeminal
nucleus so this is my
little vignette make up
your own um as needed
and i hope that was
helpful here is a cross
section through the mid
pons that's going to
be showing the placement
for various nuclei
for the cranial nerve
seven here we have a
image showing the flow
of information from
various nuclei to their
destination like the
facial motor nucleus
that will be within
the brain stem and then
it will be targeting
the upper and lower
musculature of the face
we have the salivatory
nucleus superior
salivatory nucleus
traveling out of the brain
targeting a peripheral
ganglion which will
then relay efferents
to the lacrimal gland i
encourage you to look
through this and try to
get some insight the
facial motor nucleus
will control the upper
and lower half of the
face on that side so
have ipsilateral control
of the upper and
lower half of the face
that nucleus for a
given side of the brain
stem will receive
input from the cerebral
cortex on both sides
so this is indicated by
yellow and orange for
the left and the right
side of the cerebral
cortex so that will
target the left and
right cerebral cortex vis
-a-vis the bolt cortical
bulbar tract will
target a given facial
motor nucleus on one side
now where the complexity
comes in is that
the cortical control
is not fully bilateral
it's only going to be
bilateral for the upper
half of the face so
you can see that the
musculature the that's
what's trying to
indicate here is that the
control of the muscles
for one half of the
face is both for the
left and the right
that's why it's going to
be alternating yellow
and orange here Whereas
for the lower half of
the face, it's just
going to be a single
color, indicating that
the cranial nerve nuclei
will receive cortical
balbar input from
just one side of the
cerebral cortex, the
contralateral side. Because
of this complex
relationship of the
corticobulbar input to
the facial motor nuclei,
we could have different
patterns of paralysis
reflecting different
origins for the
dysfunction. If one was
to have a paralysis of
the lower half of the
face, in theory, you
could have damaged the
cranial nerve just for
that inferior division.
Alternatively, you
could have damaged the
upper motor neurons
above it so that you
still had intact the
ability to raise one's
eyebrows but lost the
ability to control
that muscles of facial
expression on the lower
half because those would
be entirely driven
by the corticobulbar
tracts of the contralateral
cerebral cortex.
Alternatively, if you
lost motor control
for the entire half of
the face, that could
be tracked back to
nerve or nuclear damage
on the same side was
damage to that nerve
the entire cranial
nerve seven then you
would also have a
dysfunction amongst all
the other information
that would be relayed
through that nerve
so that would include
taste for the interior
two thirds of the tongue
and ability to produce
saliva would be
diminished and you'd
hear louder sounds on
that side of your ear
because you would no
longer have control of
the stupideous muscle.
We're moving now to
cranial nerve eight
which is the vestibular
cochlear nerve
and that will be yoked
to the vestibular
and cochlear nuclei.
That's really
quite simple. We
can see for each
nuclei, there's only
one nerve that is
involved, and these
are entirely sensory.
The nucleus is going
to be processing
information from the
cochlea related to hearing,
and the vestibular
nucleus is going to
be processing information
from the various
vestibular organs
related to how your head
is moving in external
space you'll soon
see that the vestibular
nucleus is extremely
large and it's going
to be communicating
to the cerebellum
it's going to be
communicating to various
um nuclei for ocular
motor control vis-a
-vis the MLF there's the
vestibular spinal
tracts for controlling
the orientation
of the head
and the extension
of the legs
here we have a section
transverse section
of upper medulla that
will show the very
small cochlear nucleus
on the lateral just
lateral to this now very
large inferior cerebellar
peduncle that will
be traveling to the
cerebellum medial to
that pretty much up
to this point is the
vestibular nucleus at
this level and it goes
considerably further
below so this is really
is quite a massive
nucleus There's many
subnuclei within that
for a variety of
functions, but we put that
all together as, say,
vestibular nucleus.
Just a small list
of conditions
that could impact cranial
nerve and its
associated nuclei.
One could have acute
exposure to ethanol at
a level such that it
changes the osmolarity
of the endolymph
of the semicircular
canals and this would
trick the system into
thinking that it is
moving because you have
a displacement of the
membrane at the end
that's incorrectly
saying oh I'm spinning
this way or I'm spinning
that way and it's
going to be disorganized
as well And that
would be vertigo.
Now we have Meniere's
disease, which is a very
well-known condition,
though rare, where
there's a triad of
symptoms of diminished
ability to detect sound
at particular frequencies,
high frequencies,
and a sense of oral
fullness. and then
you also feel that
you're spinning. It's a
very disruptive condition
that can come on
pretty much all of a
sudden, and then it
can last for hours
and hours and hours.
And so that's why it's
well known is because
it's so debilitating.
Don't know exactly
where the cause
is, but we have
inflammation of the canals
is a good possibility.
Other things is
if you disrupt the
vestibular nucleus
itself, you could have
a loss of ability to
really maintain oneself
upright and activate
those leg muscles
on the ipsilateral
side appropriately.
So these are things that
you should keep in mind.
Moving on to
cranial nerve 9, the
glossopharyngeal nerve,
we can have the boxes
on the sensory side
saying um that these
are the nuclei that
are going to be um
targeted by information
conveyed by this
nerve so i'm looking
for this um roman nine
symbol in here and
lo and behold i see
it and i see it for
the solitary nucleus
as well and for
nucleus and biggest and
for the inferior
salivatory. So this nerve
is going to be having
motor and sensory
functions relayed by it.
Cranial nerve nine is
going to be conveying
information to and
from a number of
nuclei. Let's start
with the motor ones.
Nucleus embigus, this
has a brachial motor
function. Most of the
efferents from this
nucleus are conveyed
through cranial nerve 10,
but a particularly
important one is through
cranial nerve 9 that
is directed to the
stylopharyngeus muscle,
which is an important
particular phase of
swallowing. We have the
inferior salivatory
nucleus. It's going to
be targeting that large
gland located within
the cheek. We have
afferents that will be
targeting the gustatory
nucleus for taste.
This would be originating
from the posterior
one-third of the
tongue. You may remember
that the anterior two
-thirds would be via
cranial nerve seven, so
this would be the rest.
We have some baroreceptive
feedback to the
solitary nucleus.
And lastly, we have a
little bit more information
coming up from the
periphery destined to
the trigeminal nucleus
this would be for the
both divisions the
pontine and spinal
divisions of the trigeminal
nucleus for sensing
the posterior one
-third of the tongue as
well as the throat in
the ear so the anterior
one-third of the tongue
was through the
trigeminal nerve the the
rest of touch the rest
of somatic sensation
for the tongue for touch
proprioception pain
temperature all that
would be now here being
relayed through cranial
nerve nine seeing
some From different
nuclei that had not come
up before, the nucleus
embigus, which has
most of its output
conveyed through the vagus
nerve, but there is
one important set of
axons that will be targeting
the silo pharyngeus
muscle, and those will
be relayed through
cranial nerve 9. This
is important for a
particular phase of
swallowing. Now, we have
the inferior salivatory
nucleus. This is going
to be targeting that
very large gland for
salivation. In the cheek,
we have the rest of
taste for the tongue
that is going to be
the posterior. one-third
of the tongue is going
to be its information
is going to be heading
to the nuclear
gustatory nucleus the
gustatory nucleus is
going to be getting the
information from the
anterior and for the entire
tongue it's a matter
of which nerve does
it go through for
cranial nerve seven would
be the anterior two-third
for the for the rest
is going to be through
CN9. We have solitary
nucleus. This is going
to be some baroreceptor
feedback from the
sinus and the body.
We have the trigeminal
nucleus again. This
would be for the
posterior one-third of the
tongue. So the anterior
one-third of the
tongue was again cranial
nerve uh nine and uh
so this is a complex
nerve um arguably more
complex than cranial
nerve seven because i
don't have a good
vignette for this i mean i
thought of one involving
like a hot pepper
but it never really
and you know swallowing
it just never really
worked so let's just
go back to the name of
the nerve aside from
nine which is
glossopharyngeal so much of
this is related to
that nerve and that's
why they called it such
right the anatomists
were on the right track
here so glasso means
the tongue and it's
going to be related
to speak so no glossary
right there is this
word glossalia which
is like to speak in
tongues as if one was
inspired it's not of
actual words but you're
you're saying word
-like things and then
there's the fairing so
all of these functions
would kind of fall
within that the
glossopharyngeal function so
I really think that
that's the best way of
getting a handle on
what is being conveyed
through this and then
knowing the nuclei
associated with that
I think that's going
to be pretty straightforward
here is a section
through the medulla
where we have the
glossopharyngeal nerve
entering and exiting.
You might remember
that six, seven, eight
are going to be on
that ponto medullary
junction and the
glossopharyngeal is going
to be one starting
to travel down the
length of the medulla.
so the nuclei for
the related to this
nerve they're going to
be many of them are
going to be nearby
this level and then
we have the placements
of the nuclei in
this medial lateral
arrangement according
to the functions that
we've talked about
before motor is medial
and sensory is lateral
Last anatomical
image for the
glossopharyngeal nerve cranial
nerve 9 and the
afferents and efferents
related to it,
as well as the
nuclei, the
motor and sensory
nuclei that are
related to that.
And this is just
to help provide an
understanding of
the geometry of
those nuclei within
the brainstem.
Now on to cranial nerve
10, the vagus nerve,
the wanderer. We can
see that the vagus
nerve will be conveying
information that is
going to be ultimately
yoked to the nucleus and
vagus, dorsomotor
nucleus of the vagus on
the motor side, on the
sensory side to the
solitary nucleus and
trigeminal. you can see
X's in all of these
different boxed nuclei.
The vagus is going to
be conveying information
that is comparable
to what we saw with
cranial nerve 9. It's
also pretty brutal to
get a handle on these
nuclei, but there is
some overlap with what
we had before. There's
nucleus ambiguous that
we saw with cranial
nerve 9 as I mentioned
this was a brachial
motor nuclei to control
many of the things
about swallowing and
so before it was just
a single muscle here
it's everything else so
the striated muscles
for soft palate fairings
and muscles for the
vocal cords so you
really have a a lot of
opportunities to have
dysfunction of these
effectors with damage
to this cranial nerve
the dorsal motor
nucleus is going
to be providing that
parasympathetic
control to so many
different parts
of our body including
the gi tract and the
heart before this is
the rest and digest
functions as opposed
to the fight-and-flight
functions of the sympathetic
system the solitary
nucleus is where it
really is going to
come on board it's
also called the nucleus
of the solitary track
and so this is going
to be getting viscero
-sensory and put from a
whole pile of different
internal portions
of your body the
abdominal and thoracic
viscera as well as some
chemosensitive receptive
inputs and lastly we
have trigeminal nucleus
the skin of the back
of the ear and the
ear canal so just a
little bit more of the
ear for touch as
well as pain and
temperature sensation
going to the different
divisions of the
trigeminal nucleus I
want to highlight that
the vagus nerve is
really thought of
uh often for this
parasympathetic uh
function in terms of
efference as as it
should that's good but
most of the relationship
to the um the
abdominal and
thoracic viscera
and the heart
and so on these
portions of the
they're under autonomic
control most of that
processing vis-a-vis the
cranial nerve are
things going up to the
solitary nucleus so 80%
up to 80% are autonomic
afferents not
efferents and so that's
really neat right it's
like only could be 40
to even just 20% are
on the motor side to
those organs and 80
is going to be sensory
information from and
people really don't
think about that when
they're talking about
the vagus nerve and
its relationship to the
periphery the autonomic
systems but lots
of it is feedback
i find that very
compelling This
transverse section through
the medulla is going
to be one where
we can see some of
the nuclei associated
or yoked through
cranial nerve 10.
i'm pointing
out s right here
that's going to
be the solitary
nucleus and
then mx this is
dorsal motor nucleus
and i want to point
out two other things
one is that the
ambiguous nucleus is
through a huge territory
and we're not really
pointing to it
very clear like here's
the ambiguous nucleus
it's like literally
within this territory
and that's why it's
called ambiguous
because it with these
standard staining
techniques it's very
unclear to identify
this kind of concentrated
uh clusters it's
kind of a little bit
intermingled so it's
called ambiguous which
is like literally
they're shrugging their
shoulders and going
i i don't know it's
it's it's a vowel
right here and so
that's why it's called
ambiguous um also this
image allows us to see
the solitary tract and
so you may remember
from the previous
slide that the
solitary nucleus is
also called the nucleus
of the solitary
tract and this is
where there's kind
of a little bit of
irony because the
the nucleus solitary
nucleus should not be
considered solitary
right because it's
getting inputs from
everywhere of the viscera
right there's so much
visceral information
traveling to it so it's
not lonely it's not
solitary so why do we
get this name solitary
nucleus well because
of the tract the
tract stands out as so
distinct within this
territory of the solitary
nucleus and the dorsal
motor nucleus and
so that's why it
can be more properly
understood as the nucleus
of the solitary tract
the solitary tract
really stands out alone
by itself the efferents
of nucleus and
biggest travel out
through cn10 to innervate
the ipsilateral
throat. So if you had a
lesion at the level
of that nucleus or the
nerve, you would have
ipsilateral paralysis.
In contrast, that
nucleus, like most of
the others of the
cortical bulbar system
received bilateral
input from cerebral
cortex and that means
a lesion to the cortex
of the bilateral of
the representation
of the throat on one
side would be compensated
for by the other
side of cerebral
cortex or unilateral
cortical lesion will
be largely compensated
so there's a variety
of ways that you can
have damage to the
cranial nerve as well
as the nuclei that
are yoked to this
nerve one example is
a aneurysm or tumors
in the throat and neck
and we're talking about
the control of the
the soft palate, the
pharynx, the larynx,
so you'd have issues
with hoarseness in
speaking, difficulties
in swallowing, problems
with the gag reflex.
This is going to be
the most immediate
thing that's going to
come to your attention.
There are also
autonomic dysfunctions
that can result because
of that loss of
parasympathetic drive, as
well as altered sensory
information coming
up from the from the
viscera to feedback
from the viscera and
the end result of that
could be some issues
with acid reflux or
a more rare case where
we have paralysis or
near paralysis of the
GI system gastroparesis
which is very very
serious, but rare.
Now we're back to
something simple again.
That was tough
before. Now we're
simple, so it's all
good. Take a breath.
So cranial nerve 11, the
spinal accessory nerve,
is going to be yoked
to just one nucleus,
the spinal accessory
nucleus. It's called that
because of how caudal
the nucleus is found
within in the medulla
but also within the
spinal cord final
accessory nuclei for the
spinal accessory nerve
will be targeting the
sternocleidomastoid
and upper trapezius
muscle on the same side
so the SCM is going
to be involving in
turning the head to the
side and then the upper
trapezius shrugging
that shoulder some
people have reported that
the cortical ball bar
projections to this
nucleus is ipsilateral
and when i tracked
down the uh did a
thorough literature search
for that i did find
evidence for that from
some studies um but
we are going to stick
with bilateral control
because that's the most
common thing that's
reported you know a
lecture three years
from now maybe there's
going to be some more
definitive evidence but
let's just say that
this is something
that's up in
the air but we
will stick with
bilateral control
uppermost reaches of
the spinal accessory
nucleus are within
the lower most
portion of the medulla
we know that we're
in the lower most
portion of the medulla
because we have this
pyramidal decussation
right you do not
no longer have two
clear cell uh i mean
two clear columns
um we now can see the
decussation so we're
at the lowest um
portion of the medulla
and right here where
you would have the
ventral horn we have
the spinal accessory
nucleus so it really is
a continuation of that
ventral horn. This
image will be showing
how long and caudal is
the spinal accessory
nucleus, most of it
being located within
the spinal cord going
all the way down to
C5. We have the
efferents emanating from
that nuclei which must
travel up through the
foramen magnum and
then down through the
jugular foramen to target
the SEM and trapezius
muscles so there's
a very long journey
that they may need to
make up over and then
down and so that makes
them susceptible to
damage so damage to
cranial nerve 11 or to
the nucleus would lead
to the same dysfunction
which is atrophy of
the target muscles
like we have this
trapezius palsy it's really
quite evident for her
our left arm you can
see the winged scapula
this is because she
wore a really heavy
backpack and that's what
caused it but most
often what causes this
palsy is because of a
doctor doing surgery
and accidentally causing
some damage along
the way. Like if you're
going to be going
through the posterior
cervical triangle to get
a biopsy of one of
the many lymph nodes
that can be accessed
through there, then you
can damage nerve and
so that sort of injury
is called iatrogenic
so iatrogenic injury
is the most common
cause for this sort of
palsy okay the last
cranial nerve number 12 the
hypoglossal nerve yoked
to the hypoglossal
nucleus you like to
remember that the
hypoglossal nerve is seen
on the ventral surface
of the medulla just
medial to the olives
and so that would be
seeing the nerves as they
exit on out the nuclei
is actually found
at the all the way
on the other side
it's a motor nucleus
has to be behind
this medial
lemniscus and the the
pyramids it's
very very distinct
nuclei just by this
fourth ventricle
for nuclei are going
to be innervating all
of the internal
muscles and most of the
external muscles of the
tongue here is an example
of somebody that has
severe atrophy of
their tongue on one
side and we can see how
much loss of muscle
there was right you can
see that there's just
huge gaps here because
it's like you deflated
a tire and the
tongue is kept in cheek
in the lips because
as soon as they stick
their tongue out we can
see it just flops to
the side so it's just
kept in check by
being in this lips as
soon as they drop their
lip it popped to the
top to the side and
because we have this
unopposed action from
the um intact tongue
muscles so the tongue
will deviate to the weak
side and um this is
something that you
should be you know
looking for this maybe was
a isolated issue or
was a consolation of
problems of a deviated
uh tongue a deviated
ovula for the soft palate
hoarseness all those
things together are
going to allow you to
track down whether
it's restricted to a
nerve or is it going
to be something that's
going to involve a
particular region of the
brainstem or maybe it's
going to be involving
the cerebral cortex
now we're going to be
talking about a couple
of brainstem strokes
that will involve a
cluster of symptoms which
you should be able to
understand given the
material in the
preceding slides. So if
you had a ****** of the
interior spinal artery
which would be supplying
this region shown
in blue and dots we
would have a lesion of
the hypoglossal nucleus,
we'd have a lesion
to the medial laminiscus
and cortospinal
tract, and this would be
expressed as an inability
to control the
muscles of the body on
the contralateral side
and loss of touch and
proprioceptive information
for the body on
the contralateral side
and an inability to
control the tongue on
the same side. So the
tongue will point to
this side of the lesion.
Lateral medullary
syndrome occurs with a
****** of pica posterior
inferior cerebellar
artery, and there
are a large number of
structures that are impacted
because of the broad
blood supply of the
pica. So we have the
nucleus ambigus in
this territory. So as a
result, you'd have
hoarseness or difficulty
in swallowing. The
spinal thalamic tract is
found in here. So
you'd have diminished
pain and temperature
sensation on the opposite
side of the body.
We have the spinal
trigeminal nucleus and
tract. So this would be
interfering with the
ipsilateral pain and
temperature for the
face. So this would be an
alternation of pain and
temperature dysfunction.
So ipsilateral
face, contralateral
body. You could also
have some discoordination
because you're
impacting this inferior
cerebral peduncle which
is providing a great
deal of information to
the cerebellum from the
ipsilateral side of
the body and we have
the vestibular nucleus
as well so you could
have symptoms of falling
to the lateral side
so many different
symptoms that can be
expressed with a ******
to pica all right so
that's all the material
for this lecture the
summary of this
information can be found in
this slide i'm not going
to read through each
line you can go
through that on on your
own it's going to
refer obviously back to
different sections of
the material it's tough
material so just give
it a second try give
it a third try if needed
and you'll get it.
I hope the material
was clear enough it's
quite complex
material, I understand.
Feedback is appreciated.